era casi desconocido para el pueblo
libanés pero ahora fue lanzado a la luz
pública
mustafa a depp ex profesor con un
doctorado en derecho y ciencias
políticas fue nombrado jefe del gabinete
en 2011 bajo el mandato del primer
ministro y multimillonario nayib mikati
desde 2013 se desempeñaba como embajador
del líbano en alemania pero aunque está
respaldado por la mayoría de los
diputados los manifestantes ya habían
advertido que rechazarían cualquier
gobierno formado por adif el movimiento
de protestas ha permanecido a líbano
durante casi un año y los manifestantes
instaron a una revisión política después
de cansarse de la élite que ha gobernado
el líbano durante las últimas décadas
como resultado se evidencian grandes
desafíos cuando adiba asume su primer
mandato como primer ministro a los 48
años se espera que con su nuevo gobierno
saque al líbano de su crisis política y
económica cada vez más profunda que sólo
ha empeorado desde que una explosión en
el puerto de beirut dejó unos 200
muertos y destruyó parte de la capital
no hay tiempo para hablar de promesas y
deseos es hora de trabajar juntos para
sanar a nuestro país y devolver la
esperanza a nuestro pueblo de un futuro
mejor porque todos los libaneses están
extremadamente preocupados por el
presente y el futuro
hasta ahora mustafa di ha prometido
formar un gabinete de expertos para
reactivar las conversaciones estancadas
con el fondo monetario internacional
los observadores internos e
internacionales están preparados para
vigilar de cerca los cambios que exigen
al sistema político sectario del líbano
y el fm y ha dejado claro que tales
reformas son obligatorias si el país
quiere llegar a un acuerdo o rescate
justo después de ser nominado mustafa
deep se reunió con los residentes de
gemma y ser uno de los barrios más
afectados por la explosión ni su
predecesor ni el presidente michel aún
han estado en los barrios desde la
explosión del 4 de agosto